ん
飲み出すと飲まないとやっぱり寝られなくなっちゃう
本当に良くない
夜中に目覚めちゃおう?
ちょっとあと寝られないのよね
メメなんて、大気もそうだって言うんだけど
なんか
CDでね、自動的に電気がちゃんと切れるのもあるのね、プレイヤーが
それをCDを結構ガンガンかけて
それで明るくしてあって
あの廊下の方の電気がつけてあって
メメも真っ暗でも静かっていう風に狙わせないの
それ、さっきさんもそうだって言うから
ガンガンガンを見つけた
そっか
リスカ、ハワイに行った時に
なんか、あの
ハワイじゃないか
あの
ウチだったかもしれない
どこだか忘れてたんだけど
大気がそこに寝てるの
5番町かもしれない
上が5番町にいた頃に
大気のお部屋がなかったんだよね
かわいと
みんなが食事したまんまそこで
わわわ
騒いでる時に大気だけもう
お休みとか言って
寝られないそうだったんだけど
しばらくしてよく寝ちゃったのね
それでやっぱりそういう風に
うるさくて明るい方が寝られるっていうのよ
それ、メメそれよく分かるの?
メメってそうなのよ
変でしょ
うるさくなったの?
うるさくなったら
車で一番寝やすいかな
うん
ダメですね
なんか動いてる
そう
5番町にちょっといたもんね
アリシアもいたのよね
うん
よく覚えてる
いつもアリシアに会った?
あの
最近というか
全然
もう4年
今後
何か
ホットフローリーじゃん
出られなかったみたいな
うん
毎年
スピード
はい